SOME OF THOSE HE HAS RESPONDED
TO DIRECTLY, OTHERS HE HAS NOT.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW A
RESPONSE TO THE LATEST
REPORTING.
AS WE TOLD WITH THE TOP OF THE
PROGRAM PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
THERE IS NO LONGER A NUCLEAR
THREAT FROM NORTH KOREA.
HE'S ALSO DEFENDING HIS DECISION
TO HALT U.S. MILITARY EXERCISES
WITH SOUTH KOREA DURING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH KIM JONG UN'S
GOVERNMENT.
ALL OF IT IS CREATING AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE QUITE A STIR ON
CAPITOL HILL.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE HAS
TONIGHT'S REPORT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> AFTER MORE THAN 45 HOURS ON
THE GROUND AND ANOTHER 22 IN THE
AIR, PRESIDENT TRUMP RETURNED
FROM HIS HISTORIC SINGAPORE
SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN AMID
STRONG HEADWINDS OF SKEPTICISM
THAT THE SUMMIT PRODUCED PLENTY
OF DECLARATIONS BY THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT FAR FEW DETAILS.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP THE
PRESIDENT FROM UNLEASHING A
TWEET STORM OF OPTIMISM
DECLARING THE WORLD HAS TAKEN A
BIG STEP BACK FROM POTENTIAL
NUCLEAR CATASTROPHE.
IF THERE IS NO LONGER A NUCLEAR
THREAT FROM NORTH KOREA BEFORE
ADDING NORTH KOREA WAS OUR
BIGGEST AND MOST DANGEROUS
PROBLEM.
NO LONGER.
SLEEP WELL TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS COME UNDER
CRITICISM IN SOME CORNERS
BECAUSE OF THE ONE AND A HALF
PAGE STATEMENT THAT HE SIGNED IN
SINGAPORE, SPELLED OUT NO
SPECIFIC COMMITMENTS FROM THE
NORTH ASIDE FROM WORKING TOWARD
THE COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA, A PROMISE
THAT THE REGIME HAS REPEATEDLY
MADE AND BROKEN SINCE THE
1990s.
ON CAPITOL HILL, A FURIOUS
DEBATE OVER WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT GAVE AWAY FAR MORE
THAN HE EXTRACTED FROM THE
MEETING RAGED ON TODAY WITH
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM EXPRESSING
SKEPTICISM.
>> THE SUMMIT WAS MUCH MORE SHOW
THAN SUBSTANCE.
WHAT THE TEXANS CALL ALL CATTLE,
NO HAT.
AFTER ALL THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE HAVE FADED, IT
SEEMS CLEAR THAT KAREN AND JIM
WALKED AWAY THE VICTOR
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT MADE
PROMISES BEFORE AND IT'S BROKEN.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
PROMISES REGARDING MINOR ITEMS,
THESE ARE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
BALLISTIC MISSILES THAT HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF REACHING THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
APPLAUDED FOR DISRUPTING THE
STATUS QUO.
NOW LET'S GO GET AN AGREEMENT.
WE SHOULD BE UNDER NO DELUSION
THIS IS GOING TO BE FAST.
>> MIKE POMPEO SAYS HE EXPECTS
NORTH KOREA TO TAKE MAJOR STEPS
TOWARDS NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT
DURING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST
TERM, TELLING REPORTERS IN SEOUL
WE ARE HOPEFUL WE CAN ACHIEVE
THAT IN THE NEXT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS BEFORE ADDING THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK LEFT TO DO.
ASKED WHY THE WORDS VERIFIABLE
AND IRREVERSIBLE WERE NOT IN A
DOCUMENT SIGNED BY THE TWO
LEADERS IN SINGAPORE, MIKE
POMPEO SAID TODAY BECAUSE THE
WORDS COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION